claro que sí gracias pues mira la
respuesta en palabras del propio lópez
obrador es porque él así lo ha dicho la
gente ya entendió que se pueden hacer
las cosas de manera distinta que ya no
es lo mismo de antes los privilegios de
una élite la corrupción generalizada en
el gobierno y por ello dice lópez
obrador que pues el 70 por ciento
el promedio de encuestas a este segundo
año es del 62 por ciento lo respalda
porque precisamente se han acabado los
privilegios de los que gozaba la élite
en el poder lo cierto es que pues hay
algunos indicadores de su gobierno que
muestran que el país tiene avances en
algunos aspectos y otros retrocesos por
ejemplo en el tema precisamente del
manejo de la pandemia
-mario méxico recibió un llamado de
atención por parte de la organización
mundial de la salud por su gestión de la
pandemia ciertamente el coi 19 le ha
pasado factura a la nación
norteamericana cuéntanos también en el
marco de los años del presidente que se
espera en el futuro para la pandemia y
las medidas del gobierno
así es la situación es complicada lo
dijo el propio titular de la
organización mundial de la salud en
mexico ya van más de 105 mil muertos y
va a más de un millón 113 mil contagios
confirmados a pesar de que el gobierno
había pronosticado cuando mucho 60 mil
muertos hay algunos mensajes de esta de
este discurso del jefe de la ms que bien
podrían aplicar es el caso de la
promoción del cubrebocas de los líderes
que deben poner el ejemplo en el uso del
cubrebocas y es conocido por todos que
el presidente de lópez obrador ha sido
reacio a promover el uso de la
mascarilla cierto es que bueno él ha
comentado que recibió el sistema
hospitalario en ruinas que estaba en
completo abandono y que su gobierno ha
logrado que no se sature en los
hospitales que todos los pacientes
tengan atención y que pues sean
recibidos en las unidades médicas lo
cierto es que hay algunos estados de la
república que van
y volver al color rojo del semáforo
epidemiológico por los rebrotes que han
estado obteniendo y la pandemia está
lejos de ser tomada como en su momento
lo dijo el propio presidente el
escenario aún es incierto esperamos por
cierto la llegada de la vacuna pero las
cifras van en constante aumento